[Music]
hey you guys it's october 30th and this
is the penultimate installment of my eek
week halloween week movie review series
and even though i said i was going to do
more family-friendly stuff uh that'll be
for tomorrow
for today we're actually doing
one of my i guess beloved b movie uh you
know b horror movie schlock from the
1980s late 1980s i first saw this uh
run it from the video store as i guess
most people did uh back in the late
1980s and quickly became a favorite it's
just kind of like there's something
about this particular movie that even
though it's really schlocky and really
cliched you could even say that i don't
i don't think i'd go as far as to call
it like an evil dead rip-off but you can
tell that you know that they were really
into evil dead and wanted to use some of
the stuff in it but
honestly there's something about the
vibe of this movie that really kind of
elevates it and i think that it's one of
the reasons why it's one of the better
remembered kind of 80s schlock horror
classics this is of course 1988's knight
of the demons now this movie i was like
watching it's fascinating if you go on
youtube as at least as uh as
at the time of this recording there's
actually a documentary it's about an
hour and 17 minutes long
and it's called you're invited and it's
all about the making of this movie and
it's really really interesting they got
like pretty much all the cast members
back like to talk about it all the
filmmakers and all this kind of stuff
and it's just um you can tell they had a
really good time making this movie and
you wouldn't necessarily think it
because of you know like i said it's
reputation as being this kind of like
schlocky b horror not it's not really a
slasher it's almost kind of like a
combination slasher sort of like demony
evil dead type of movie but there
actually was some really uh great talent
behind it and you know so it is so it
just goes to show just because the movie
was cheap or whatever
uh that doesn't mean that there weren't
a massive masses of talent going on
behind the camera so this was actually
directed by kevin s tenney tenney
and he had done witchboard prior uh in
1986 which is another movie i need to
get to because i actually
remember liking that a lot i think i saw
it a bunch of times on cable back in the
day
and uh he wasn't it's weird because i
was watching like an interview with him
and he wasn't like a big horror movie
fan
um but he just kind of ended up making
them because i guess they were cheaper
and that's what the market was and
everything like that so it's just funny
to like to hear him to talk about it so
a lot of the stuff that came out about
this movie was almost kind of like i
don't want to say it was like accidental
but they didn't really do it on purpose
exactly this movie um initially when
they were conceiving it it was supposed
to be called halloween party which you
know i'm not gonna that's kind of a dumb
title i'm saying but so i'm glad they
did call it that but it was originally
called halloween party but what ended up
happening was that the guy that was the
producer on john carpenter's halloween
uh mustafa cod i think his name is he
basically i don't think he was
threatening them necessarily but he was
basically like well you can't use that
title because
like you know what i mean and i didn't
realize that because the movie you know
john carpenter's halloween was called
halloween i didn't realize that you
couldn't
call anything halloween blah you know
what i mean so but i guess i don't know
if that was like really true or not but
he basically said yeah you can't call it
halloween party because then i'm gonna
sue you or whatever so then like
put in a nice way uh i'm gonna sue you
in a nice way but uh so yeah so they had
to end up changing the name to
knight of the demons they said
everything
that they had done up to that point like
all the marketing because i think the
movie was done through because they said
during the whole entire filming it was
called halloween party and honestly they
even had to redo
like part of the credits like the
opening credit sequence which i'll get
to in a minute because that's one of my
favorite things about this movie but
because they had already made the title
sequence that had the title halloween
party on it so they had to do when they
did um the title night of the demons
they had to just like make it
they had to like make it bigger than the
original titles they could like paste it
over like on the film which i thought
was really funny and also can we talk
about the long animated sequence which
starts this like the long credit
sequence at the beginning because like i
said earlier that i was going to bring
that up wow i really really love the
animated sequence at the beginning of
this and it was actually done by a woman
who was an animator at disney and she
was kind of like known as the go-to
person for doing disney villains like
she'd worked on aladdin she worked on
jafar she did ursula from little mermaid
so she was kind of that person
and uh they wanted her to do it because
i guess they were she was like friends
with some of the filmmakers on this so
she ended up doing this gorgeous like
animated sequence which
you know if you see it you it's very
clearly uh inspired by
knight on ball mountain from fantasia
which she said that's what she wanted
that's the look that she wanted cause
she always loved tonight on ball
mountain and uh so she made something
that was kind of like that and honestly
they went back and forth because like
one of the producers and or i think it
was the director and he's like look can
we can we please just have like a plain
uh you know credit sequence because like
this is going to be costing me way too
much money it's like i could actually
use that money in other ways but once
they saw like some of the rough cut of
the credit sequence like the animation
they're like man that looks so cool
though and it's like but you know it
cost them a lot of money but they said
in the end it was kind of worth it and i
totally agree because it's really really
cool looking so yeah that's actually one
of the highlights of the movie for me is
that really long animated sequence and
they said it was really funny because at
first because like i said to save money
they were trying to they said we'll do
the animated sequence but we'll only do
like the you know the five big names on
the cast or crew or whatever so it won't
be super long but then once people
started seeing like the rough cut they
were just kind of like no i want to be
and i want to be in the animated one too
so they had to make it like three and a
half four minutes long to like
accommodate everybody and it ended up
costing them a [ __ ] ton of money but
honestly um it looks so cool that you
know you can't really argue with the
effectiveness so i'm kind of glad that
they spent the extra money to do it so
what happens in this movie like i said
it's not uh super original it's not you
know like this great conceptual like art
film or anything like that it's just
like a very fun
throwaway 80s movie
uh so you got this goth chick angela
and she is throwing a halloween party
at this place called hull house which is
like a former mortuary and there was all
kind of other like shenanigans that went
on there i think there's some uh stuff
about necrophilia and some murders that
went on there and stuff like that and
also uh you find out later on in the
movie
there's also uh the old 80s
thing of it's built over an indian
burial ground or you know there's a
there's a story in there about
a native american who
went crazy on the property because it's
supposedly possessed and then he killed
his wife and made a tepee out of her
intestines or something like that so
it's like there's all that kind of stuff
so so she's having a party she's kind of
the weird girl but i guess everybody
just thinks it's you know it's halloween
night so so let's go to the scariest
party possible uh she also has a friend
named suzanne played by the awesome
linnaea quigley who's always fun to see
she's just like a super fun she seems
like a super fun lady and she had been
in a bunch of horror movies prior to
this i'm pretty sure uh sorority babes
in the slimeball bowl of ramo was before
this one maybe like the year before but
i guess when they cast her the guy that
cast her didn't realize that she'd been
in a [ __ ] ton like he knew that she'd
been in some horror movies but didn't
know that she was like scream queen like
everybody was into it
and it's interesting because i was
watching an interview with her about
this movie too and she said well they
kept calling me like wanted me to be on
this movie and she's like and i at first
i didn't want to do it because they're
supposed to be high school kids and
she's like and i was like 26 or 27 and
she's like and i look too old you know
she's and she was saying that i'd had
experience of going around you know to
audition for other movies and them
saying yeah you're too old to be like a
high school student but she's like when
she got there she's like they just kept
calling and calling so finally i went
and she's like i didn't even have to
audition really they just gave me the
part because they just wanted her so you
know but like i said that's kind of like
if that's going back to the 1950s it's
like you know all these [ __ ] horror
and sci-fi like b movies and they
obviously these quote-unquote high
school students that all look like
they're about 30 years old and everybody
does in this one too and it's fine even
though i'm pretty sure i think the one
guy that plays sal in this i think he
said that he was only 18 like during the
filming of this movie and it's crazy
like when you see him in the uh
documentary he looks like almost
unchanged it's the craziest [ __ ] ever
the first time you see lynnae quigley uh
very famously it's very i mean most of
her shots in this it's it's not as quite
as famous as like return of the living
dead like the naked gravestone dance but
it's getting up there it was one of the
things that i always remembered is that
her introduction is basically just this
massive shot of her ass
it's just these little pink panties like
over her butt and she's like leaning
over in a convenience store
distracting the two clerks so that
angela can steal a bunch of [ __ ] for
their halloween party because they're
not paying for [ __ ] you know what i mean
so so yeah she's dressed as bo peep i
think she's a little bo peep is what
she's supposed to be and uh amelia
kinkade uh or mimi for short that's what
they kept calling her uh she plays
angela in this and she's great now she
was actually better known she'd been in
some movies and stuff but i think she
was better known as a dancer uh she and
choreographer and stuff she was like a
backup dancer for a bunch of uh you know
live shows um she mentioned like a whole
bunch of them like smokey robinson and
diana ross and stuff like that so she'd
been like a backup dancer and then she
was also in a bunch of music videos uh
most famous ones she mentioned was uh
stray cat sexy in 17. she was like the
main girl in that so that's kind of what
she was known for and because
the script of this like called for kind
of an extended dance sequence and uh she
so she wanted to do it they wanted
somebody that was actually a dancer and
they actually let her choreograph her
own thing which is actually kind of cool
and one of the things that kind of made
me fall in love with this movie like
when i first saw it on video was because
i didn't really i mean growing up in the
late 80s i didn't see
i mean there were some but i didn't see
a lot of movies that had you know music
i liked it like goth music and stuff and
so it was really cool to see this long
extended sequence of this goth chick
dancing to the bauhaus song stigmata
martyr uh you know with the
with the flashing light the strobe light
and everything i just thought that was
so cool like back in 1988 or 1989 or
whenever it was that i saw this movie
because i was just kind of like oh boy
like a god chick and she's listening to
past that's so neat i just thought that
was so cool so yeah so those two are the
ones having the party and then you have
kind of like your stock
uh you know few characters that are
going to this party you have kind of
like the douchey guy that's like not i
couldn't figure out if he was wearing a
costume or
because he looked like miami vice but
then i was kind of like well but people
did wear that kind of [ __ ] back then
like not ironically or like not as a
costume and his girlfriend did say
something about i thought we were gonna
wear costumes and then i was like well
is he not in costume no i thought he was
don johnson but i guess not uh that guy
was the same guy that was in heather's
like a year i had forgotten that dude
was uh was in that movie because i was
like hey it's kurt or
ram which one's which i can't remember
but he played either kurt or i think he
was kurt uh kurt or ram in the uh in the
in heather's so he was in there and then
you kind of had your token like fat dude
that was like the comic relief uh the
gross disgusting fat guy
who's called stooge
and he's wearing a pig nose at the
beginning so that's his costume he has a
pig nose and also he has
jack-o'-lantern underwear they said they
interviewed him as well like for the
documentary and they said he said yeah
they asked me to like actually because
there's a scene like ver at the
beginning when they're on the way to the
party where there's this old fart that's
like walking down the street and they're
like yelling out the car at him and you
know and stooge like hangs his ass out
the window and he was he's like well
they were i was supposed to like
actually moon them but he's like yeah no
you can't afford that it's like
that's way that's way above your pay
grade like to see my bare ass it's like
so he had like the jack-o'-lantern
panties instead which you know that was
kind of funny well i think they thought
that they wouldn't be able to see the
jack-o'-lantern underwear and they were
like no we actually have to see your
butt and he's just like no that's not
happening so they didn't do it so you
can still you can see the
jack-o'-lantern though but yeah so you
got that you got uh the kind of final
girl type girl who's dressed like alice
uh you know alice from alice in
wonderland and then you have like a
couple of other
sort of stock characters that aren't
really all that i'm trying to think of
what their costumes were one girl was
peter pan and then her boyfriend was
like a doctor was he like a doctor or
something i feel like he had a
stethoscope and uh you know so so
there's all this kind of uh shenanigans
going on so they all go to this uh this
house where or this former mortuary
which of course is kind of like all
falling apart and shitty and it's all
creepy and everything and that's where
they're gonna have the party and fun
fact too i actually i would have never
known this if i hadn't watched the
documentary they said the house they
shot that at they said it's not there
anymore it got torn down and they said
it's a ralph's supermarket now
or at least it was at the time they
interviewed the people for the
documentary they said it looks like
because of matte paintings and stuff
like that the house looks like it's kind
of by itself like on this hill with this
big like wall around it and everything
they said the crazy thing is that this
is absolutely in downtown l.a like on
this on like a busy street corner and i
was like movie magic i mean they must
have really done like some really good
map paintings because i i mean you can
tell it's a matte painting but i didn't
realize that
this house was like literally right
there they're like yeah it's like a busy
downtown street um so and you would
never know that like from watching i
guess i didn't really think about it and
uh yeah and they also incorporated
because they said we got this property
like pretty cheap because it was you
know kind of in rough condition and it
was kind of in a shitty neighborhood and
uh originally i think they said that
the uh in the script it said that
somebody was supposed to get impaled
because it's supposed to be surrounded
by a wooden fence but they said actually
when we got to the property and it had
this kind of wall around it that is not
as big as it looks on camera but they
said you know we used some camera tricks
to like to make it look bigger but um so
they actually rewrote uh parts of the
script to accommodate the house that
they ended up getting which like i said
i always think that's a good thing to do
in horror movies is if you got a really
good location which is a really good
location then you know you can always
like tweak the script to
fit you know fit in with the narrative
and stuff and they said they were able
to like set up different rooms and
you know film the different rooms and
stuff like that i will say too that the
makeup effects because basically what
happens like i said it's not a super
complicated story or anything like that
it's basically like an 80 schlocky uh
you know horror movie like evil dead or
whatever is they start having a party um
they decide that they're going to have a
seance but not like an actual stance
it's kind of more like
the peter pan girl says no we should do
a past life seance where we all look
into a mirror and we see our past lives
which i've never heard of that but okay
maybe that's the thing
so they find this old mirror uh there's
40 bajillion like fake scares up to that
so you know if you don't like the fake
jump scare thing this movie is just
gonna like get right
get right on your nerves because it's
basically like every five minutes
somebody's coming up and putting their
hand on somebody's shoulder or
somebody's screaming and then like oh
never mind i just you know dropped
something on my toe or something that
doesn't happen but it's like it's that
kind of stuff there's tons and tons of
fake scares in this but i'll forgive it
just because one it was the 80s and two
this movie is super fun so you know sue
me so they're all looking in the mirror
and then one of the girls like flips out
because she sees like this thing that
looks like a demony dragony sort of
situation like behind her and she freaks
out and then so it turns out that i
guess it was this demon that was sort of
trapped down in the basement which is
like the crematorium and it gets out
and much like an evil dead uh it
possesses the first person who's
standing there with her mouth hanging
open who turns out to be lynette quickly
because she's standing there one of her
things is that she's always she's got
this compact and she's always like
fixing her makeup like i have to look
pretty for the boys you know what i mean
so she's always doing that kind of stuff
which comes at a play later on so she's
standing there like putting lipstick on
so this you know this wisp of smoke like
goes in her mouth so now she's possessed
and then um she actually starts making
out with angela which passes the demon
to her
uh and then chaos ensues as every time
somebody gets
possessed by the demon it's kind of like
you know goes around like a disease kind
of so you know so everybody's kind of
getting picked off one by one but then
they're coming back as demons and i kind
of like that they did i mean this is
very similar like i said to evil dead
also very similar to demons the italian
one you know that was set in the um in
the movie theater like the dario argento
produced ones lamperto baba i think
directed that one um so yeah so it's
kind of a similar premise to that but
i don't know there's just something like
i said there's something about this one
that is just really
fun i think it's probably because one
the special effects like the demon
makeup and stuff
so the guy that did the makeup for this
had just he had actually worked on some
really big movies i think he worked on
ghostbusters he worked on videodrome he
wasn't like the main guy but he was like
one of the assistants
and when this movie was being made he
had just gone out on his own and like
started his own company so this was
going to be his first job where he was
like the head of special effects but he
totally knew his [ __ ] i mean he really
knew what he was doing um and it shows
because some of the effects in this are
really really cool like and all the
demon makeup like i said they kind of
made them look different like per you
know for whatever the person was like
the the makeup on lynnea quigley looks
really awesome like all the [ __ ]
teeth and the crazy eyes and she really
she really looks uh horrifying and like
obviously angela looks really good too
the other ones they didn't do as much i
guess because those two you know women
were kind of the main uh you know
attraction i suppose but uh you know
some of the other ones there's there's a
great scene with like an arm ripping off
um and then the arm comes to life and
like grabs somebody's ankle again very
evil dead like so you can tell that that
was a big influence but
probably the most famous effect scene in
this but not probably and definitely the
most famous effect sequence in this is
lynnea quigley after she's kind of
possessed and she's sitting in this
bathroom and she kind of she pulls her
shirt open because it's lena quigly so
she has to be naked in the movie at some
point that's just like the law so but
she has her lipstick which she has been
you know [ __ ] with for throughout the
whole movie she draws kind of all over
her face
and uh then she kind of takes it like
down her chest and like starts drawing
spirals around her boob and then like
the lipstick she sticks the lipstick
like right into her tit like right at
her nipple and then it just closes right
back up and it looks really good i mean
obviously they made you know a
prosthetic
chest
but
it just it looks really great i mean you
can tell it's fake but it doesn't look
really overtly fake because like i said
the special effects guy that worked on
this had also worked on video jerome
which obviously has that scene where you
know james woods reaches into his
stomach and like pulls the videotape out
so he did it like much similar to how
they did that even though obviously the
budget on this wasn't i'm sure it wasn't
nearly as much as the budget on video
drum was this one was like made super
super cheaply but
i guess because they got so much talent
on board
you know particularly with the special
effects uh team
that it really doesn't it's really
punching above his weight above its
weight as far as special effects go
because like i said they really got a
guy that had been in the industry a long
time um and it worked on a lot of really
big special effects heavy movies it's
just that he had never you know headed
the team before so this is the first one
that he got to do and he was very very
enthusiastic about it actually also fun
fact he ended up marrying lynnea quigley
uh they met on this set i don't
obviously they you know they divorced
and he married again later on but yeah
so he was talking about because he's
talking about you know it's
the makeup took a really really long
time to put on like i think one point i
think it might have been angela's makeup
that you know especially like the burn
one where she puts her hands in the fire
and like her hands catch on fire
whatever they said that took like 11
hours to do so you would just kind of
like had to sit there and stuff so he
was just kind of like so you really got
to know these people like up close and
personal because you were sitting there
for like 11 hours like putting makeup on
them so yeah so hit so him and lynnea
were married for a little while oh i
forgot to mention too fun fact when i
was talking about uh amelia kincaid the
woman that played angela
is that she was actually not only was
she quite well known as like a dancer
and had been a lot of music videos and
stuff also rue mcclanahan's niece so
there you go
one of the golden girls also later on
she wrote a bunch of books talking about
psychically communicating with your pets
so there's that also but she seemed like
a really nice lady though they had like
um
they had a bunch of interviews with her
uh on this documentary that i watched
and she seemed super fun also and
everybody on this they're like yeah it
was it was strenuous it was like hard
like all the special effects it was like
really hard to do and stuff like that
but they all seemed like they had a
[ __ ] blast making this they're like
we just had such a good time everybody
was just like practical joker you know
practical jokers and all this other kind
of stuff and they just thought it was
super super fun i always want i also
want to mention the guy the one
and it's kind of funny the token black
guy that was in this right i think his
name's alvin alexis
and he was uh they interviewed him
extensively too and he said honestly
he's like i had come out to la
and i had a return ticket he was from
new york and he's like [ __ ] was it
really wasn't working out in la so he's
like so
the day like the the next day i had the
return ticket i was just gonna go back
to new york cause [ __ ] wasn't working
out and he's like but i get this phone
call and apparently the guy that they
had first cast in uh night of the demons
like had dropped out or couldn't do it
so his agent called him and was like why
don't you go down to read and he's like
yeah but the audition is the same time
as my flight back to new york so he's
like what if i go and i don't get it
then i'm kind of [ __ ] like i'm going
to be homeless because it's like this is
all the money i've got um you know what
i mean it's like my you know i don't
have any more money for rent or anything
like that but he decided like you know
and the rest is history he decided to
not get on the plane and to go to the uh
to audition and obviously he ended up
getting it he was very excited because
as most people know if you're and if you
know anything about 80s horror you know
or horror in general is that you know
the the trope is and it's a cliche for a
reason is that oh the black guy is
always like the first one to get killed
so he was very excited by the idea that
not only does he live through most of
the movie but he also like lives through
the whole movie like he actually sort of
ends up being because you know the the
girl like the alice in wonderland girl
she ends up living too but like both of
them end up surviving and he kind of
ends up saving her at the end like
pulling her over the wall and getting
her out of the mortuary so he so that
was very like appealing to him he's like
oh i was like so excited that i was like
the black guy in the horror movie that
doesn't die he actually like lives
through the whole thing and he's
actually kind of a hero so he's like
that was pretty awesome and like i said
it just it seemed like one of those
things that they didn't really mean for
that to happen or mean for that to be
the script necessarily but it just kind
of worked out really cool so you know
now the thing about this movie too like
i said uh you know kevin tenney had done
which board prior to this and i think he
did which board too as well although did
i see that i really i remember really
liking which board but it's been a while
since i've seen it so i might be totally
talking out my ass there it might be
terrible but i don't know people still
watch it nowadays so maybe it's still
good i'll give it another go go around
one of these days but um if this was one
of those movies that i think they kind
of basically had to like
i guess a lot of these kind of
low-budget movies had to do this they
basically they had to premiere it in
detroit um and they kind of went and
talked to like this guy that owned a
bunch of theater chains there and he was
like we have eighty thousand dollars uh
for advertising like we're gonna do tv
spots and newspaper and stuff but just
in detroit and we're gonna see how it
goes and then they have to kind of like
roll it out slowly so they did that
but the weird thing i think it made
three million dollars at the box office
i'm not entirely sure how much it cost
to make but i'm i'm imagining it wasn't
three million dollars but the thing
about this one is that it did okay at
the box office but this is one of those
movies and anybody that grew up in the
80s will be familiar with this it's one
of those movies that nobody like most
people didn't really see it in the
theater when it came out or it didn't
really do much business but then when it
came to video it was one of those movies
that you know if you were a teenager at
that time or like a young adult and you
would go to the you know video store
like to get a horror movie and that was
one of the ones that like everybody saw
and i think that it was because one the
cover is fantastic um you know the cover
design it's got like angel on it with
her [ __ ] up makeup
holding an invitation it's just a great
great cover very very uh striking so i
think that was the first thing that got
people's attention but also it was one
of those movies and i remember hearing
about it through like word of mouth
because they're like this one you know
yeah it's like a schlocky
kind of gorfest kind of like the evil
dead but it's just like because lynnea
quigley was in it who i was a big fan of
even back then you know sticking
lipstick in her tit and uh you know
because the gore and the makeup and [ __ ]
like that was so good that it really got
kind of like a buzz about it even you
know even back then before there was the
internet so it was kind of one of those
video store movies that you just kind of
had to see because everybody saw that
one and i think it got
its reputation really kind of got bigger
and bigger like from that like from
being that just kind of like video store
type of thing i kind of feel like
there's a lot of movies like that that
came out back then i don't know i guess
it was because you know yeah people went
to the movie theater back then um you
know obviously but it was just kind of
like if you were younger
maybe or you didn't have a car i think
that was what it was like if you were a
teenager you didn't have a car um you
know you could have your mom or
something like take you to the video
store and pick up a bunch of movies for
the weekend and you know i'm sure i'm
speaking for a lot of other people my
age too it's like we always wanted to
see all the horror movies and you'd kind
of get
you know a little bit of a of a vibe
going like with your friends and
everything it's like did you see this
one did you see this one this one was
really [ __ ] up and
all this other kind of stuff so that's
definitely um
what made this one kind of like the cult
classic that it is today even though
you know back then i guess it was just
like another one of those like when it
played in the theaters and like i said i
don't know if it got it got sort of a
wide release i guess it did start in
detroit but then like it did well so it
kind of went to way more theaters but
this was definitely one of the ones that
benefited from
video store you know the video store
boom so yeah i just feel like you know
if you watch it now like it does have
flaws obviously um you know so the
characters are kind of like not super
likable a lot of them are kind of like
cliched you know it's like oh the horse
here's the fat guy here's the virginal
girl here's this that and the other but
i don't know what it is there's just
something like there's a sense of fun
about it that
i don't get from a lot of 80s movies you
know what i mean even though this is
kind of similar it's still
just kind of a good time i do kind of
feel like in the third act it drags a
little bit because i think that once
most of the people in the mortuary have
started turning into demons then it's
kind of go but and you know i don't know
a lot of horror movies have this where
you know then it's just kind of like the
survivors like having to like creep
through the hallways like trying to
avoid the demons and everything like
that and that does kind of go on a while
but honestly that doesn't even really
bother me all that much um you know the
movie's not long it's only 89 minutes so
even though it does drag a little bit in
the third act i really think that that's
one of the only flaws that it has like i
said it's one of those movies that
it's great right around halloween
because it's set on halloween it's about
a halloween party everybody's in
costumes you know they're having a
halloween party at this mortuary and so
it really has that vibe that sense of
fun to it i have to say too that i
really really like the sort of i guess
you would call it like a story bookend
but remember when i said at the
beginning like the fat guy stooge and
he's kind of like mooning this this
crack this cranky old
bastard like that's walking down the
street and at first i kind of like that
they set it up like oh why are these
teenagers these [ __ ] you know
whippersnappers they're picking on this
old man who's just like walking home
with his groceries or whatever then it
turns out that
he uh was actually an [ __ ] so you
don't really feel bad because it turns
out at the end there's like a little
coda like after you know the survivors
escape the mortuary and the sun comes up
and they're kind of like walking home
all bedraggled like in the daylight and
then the old guy's like oh they've been
out all night those little bastards
and these are kind of like that and then
it turns out that when he was coming
back from the grocery store he'd
actually bought like a [ __ ] ton of
apples and it's just some razor blades
and he was gonna he put all the razor
blades in the apples but then it turned
out that like they didn't get any
trick-or-treaters so his uh his nice
little old grandma wife she um made
apple pie
out of all that he ate it without all of
this there's a really great like last
scene where all the um the razors are
like coming out of his neck and it's all
blood and everything and then i love the
way the his wife is just kind of like
happy halloween here like he's very
[ __ ] dead
because he told like the kids earlier
you're gonna get what you deserve you
know what i mean which i guess they kind
of did but he did too so i thought that
was kind of a nice little touch but yeah
this is definitely a movie that you put
on at a halloween party or
you know it's the night before halloween
or it's halloween night you get a bunch
of beers you get some of your friends
you get you know it's just like a fun
kind of fun party movie and uh you know
so as long as you don't expect anything
else from it i think it's definitely one
of the best ones of that genre uh from
the 1980s and if you're into 80s horror
like schlocky bihor at all you
definitely should see it like i said
there's a lot of things that elevate it
particularly the special effects which i
think still look great so yeah if you
haven't seen it definitely check it out
i think they remade it in 2009 although
i haven't heard much good about i
haven't seen it so you know i don't know
i don't have an opinion but um this one
had a that had a sequel that came out
89 90 i don't remember when the sequel
came out but it did have one sequel and
then the remake
i didn't i'm pretty sure i didn't see
the sequel and i know i didn't see the
remake but i heard the remake wasn't
very good i don't know if that's true or
not but uh knight of the demons is
available on most streaming services uh
including shutter so if you want to go
watch it on shutter that's what i would
recommend that's what i did and also um
if you know if it's still on youtube go
and check out uh it's called you're
invited uh you know the making of knight
of the demons or whatever and it's
actually really interesting like if
you're into that movie and they got
pretty much it looked like they got
pretty much the whole cast and crew
to come back and talk about it um and
it's about an hour and 17 minutes and
it's actually really interesting and
that's where i got a lot of the
information for this video so definitely
go check that out as well if you if you
would like to and that will do it for
this uh eek week installment and i will
see you guys tomorrow for actual
halloween bye
[Music]